Voilà une fleur que j’adore, l’orchidée.
Je préfère l’observer dans la nature.
Mais en période de confinement,
je vous en présente une qui vit en intérieur.
Toutes possèdent la même fleur très caractéristique.
Elle est constituée de 6 pièces florales.
3 sépales… 1,2,3 et 3 pétales
que l’on a du mal à distinguer des précédents
1,2 et le 3ème, caractéristique des orchidées : le labelle.
Souvent, il sert de piste d’atterrissage
pour les qui viennent butiner la fleur
car les organes sexuels, les étamines qui contiennent
le pollen et le pistil sont confinés tout au fond.
Parfois, ce labelle reproduit la morphologie
d’un insecte femelle ce qui attire davantage les mâles
et favorise la pollinisation.
Celui-ci est un hybride. Pour sa reproduction,
il va falloir la main de l’homme…
Mais ça fait quand même une jolie
« capsule de déconfiné »
Allez à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes toujours confinés mais on reste en lien !
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez aussi voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
Et pour être sûr de n’en rater aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
A très bientôt et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.